normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this from the New York Post rep Tim
brette accuses bully Kevin McCarthy of
attacking him with quote clean shot to
the kidneys in Capitol
hallway Yep this one's hilarious and uh
as much as they're saying it's a claim
and it's alleged an NPR reporter was
standing there recording and tweeted out
she saw this happen that McCarthy came
up from behind him and shoved him and
she thought it was a joke and then a
Chase ensued where he started yelling at
McCarthy and what brette said is that he
get he elbowed him straight in the
kidneys so this brette voted against
Kevin McCarthy McCarthy is it's it's a
mental breakdown dude Matt Gates pointed
out at our Miami event this is so
amazing So Glorious that McCarthy gets a
billion dollars or whatever in these in
these in this m you know in money for
the RNC and for his campaign and all
this stuff so he has control but you
know he owes people now he's got to
deliver a speaker of the house now that
he's removed he cannot deliver on those
promises and those IUS are now basically
toilet paper I can't imagine what it
must be like to sell your soul out to it
is effectively the mafia and then only
what like a month later be like I am no
longer in the position to pay you back I
don't think the dudes who gave you that
money will take that for an answer and
so Kevin McCarthy is probably freaking
out and sweating bullets and uh not too
happy with the people who voted against
yeah but it's also it it's just so
corrupt I mean it's this is exactly why
we should have term limits because
you're exactly right that is how DC
works but it it shouldn't be and that's
it it's just so so toxic I don't like
the idea of well lately I thought about
maybe evolving our Our House of
Representatives into like the entire
population so that we all have the
opportunity to pass to set up bills no
we still have the Senate so and the the
Republic would still they'd still be
there and if the power goes out we would
send them all to the capital so they'd
still have their job they would just be
part of the population and like deciding
bills and sending them to theate cuz
it's too easy Tobe those 450 people
M I feel like that would be really hard
to get things done I'm not I guess as
opposed to the efficiency of DC now
right but at least some stuff does
happen but maybe we just need but maybe
that's exactly why we should do that
because it would be really hard to get
stuff done maybe maybe want it depends
on what you want like if you want to
impeach mayorcas and we're not doing
that anyways perhaps that system's the
same right but if you want any funding
for the Border or anything that you do
want push through Congress then having a
convoluted system might be hard I don't
know okay well we've got a video from
Kevin McCarthy who's responded uh and
citizen Free Press says Kevin McCarthy
sounds like a man who is caught
red-handed hitting Tim brette I guess
our Shoulders hit I did not run and hit
the guy I did not kidney punch him
reporter immediately grills McCarthy
over his claims here we go a reporter
was interviewing birchard or something I
guess our shoulders it because virt runs
up to me after I didn't know what he was
talking about soter is asking me I did
not run and hit the guy I did not kidney
punch him I did not shoot anything like
that you didn't shove him no I we
walking through you you were at h35
right you guys line up along the way
there it was Bruce Wester and I walking
out he must have been interviewing
someone I didn't know it was him or
something I guess our elbow sit as I
walked by I didn't punch
youbody yeah well he I guess it happened
because when I was walking back further
I say somebody was interviewing me or
talking to me he comes running up like
why why why did you hit me or something
like that I said I don't know what
you're talking about I don't even know
something transpired but reporter of
witnesses said it looked like you there
was plenty of room for you to walk and
then you intentionally hit him where is
okay not a place show me a reporter who
saw that
ask okay well ask Bruce Wester no I did
not go up if I somebody what I
turn he's trying to like over jusy to
much
talking on now what he said the bigger
the story the bigger the LIE yeah he
would have been like no I didn't kep
walking if he didn't I didn't him the
kidneys listen twice while he was in
Congress in the chamber when have I
pushed him kininger said he was in the
back railing once and you elbowed him
and pushed him k k I don't I don't know
K you rewind that he thought that they
said Matt Gates he's got Gates on the
bra all let's let's play it you pushed
him twice while he he said he he said he
was in pain that you hit him so hard in
on now that's what he said okay that's
far
from Congress Congressman keninger wrote
that you pushed him twice he was in
Congress in the chamber when have I
pushed him kininger said he was in the
back railing once and you elbowed him
and pushed him
Gates the girl behind him said Gates
okay Congressman Gates though is filing
or uh committ submitting a complaint to
the Ethics Committee over this this
issue do you have any Congress Gates no
I I think ethics is a good place for
gates to be can I ask B said that you're
the kind of guy this his word
throw a rock and then go hide under his
mom's skirt that was what's your respon
this Congress is there bad blood between
you and berett yes none at all after he
voted to U what would you just say about
the issue of decorum in Congress I mean
there was a house oversight hearing
where a member was called to Smurf you
have over in the Senate
today you have Senator Mull
was like about to
fight this is great why do you think
things are so sorry why do you think I
think I think members have been should
have been like oh you El me in the
kidney he's got Gates on the brain yeah
and brette was at a a uh a DC young
Republicans event the night before and
called Kevin McCarthy bidder I mean they
they know what's happening this is all
all of their staffers probably talked
about all day when she asked him if he
had bad blood with that dude he looked
away and looked back at her and said no
like that's a lying when you look up to
the left that mean that's an indication
that you're lying but I guess to play
Devil's Advocate apparently there were
reporters around when this happened why
would he do it in front of a reporter
because he has no self-control yeah he's
he's having a mental breakdown dude he
was before he was even voted in a
speaker he was moving into the speaker's
office and Matt Gates called him out for
it this dude was having a temper renum
the whole time I have to imagine that
when Kevin McCarthy was facing that
showdown in the first vote to put to put
him in a speaker he was probably scared
as hell that he was not going to get it
and when he he's like I I'm just going
to move my stuff in I'm going to get it
it's going to happen I'll do what I have
to do to get it and he finally got it I
bet the dude cried I bet he went home
and he was crying like I fin speak and
then sure enough like what is it like a
month or so later like two months later
he's gone he's he's got to act as cool
and collected as he can but clearly the
dude is Unwound and he's walking down
the hallway and this dude voted to OU
him it was eight Republicans that did it
and he albow him in the back a reporter
watched it happen dude is losing his
mind yeah I can't imagine the stress
that this kind of public you know life
brings to anyone but it does seem a
little weird that you would be like
there's that guy for the first time I'll
hit him on the other hand like maybe
that is a sign that you know Congress is
as unstable as it looks from the outside
I mean at least Mark Wayne Mullins you
know formally challenged him to
basically a duel but with your hands
whereas this seems like a like cheap
shot you know like a petty Sucker Punch
type of thing yeah mullen's confronted
the guy who who who called him out and
said he wanted to fight stands up and I
love when he goes for his his wedding
ring he's like I'm take he left it on he
left it on right cuz Bernie was like Sit
Down You're son of your wife so funny
this is uh this McCarthy gu had me on
edge the entire time and I kind of kept
my mouth shut in the first few months
that he was speaker because I wanted the
best for the house but he sounded like
Trudeau the whole time his voice and he
talks like this and he has the kind of
voice and now is voice is going up and
down when he's trying it's just so
pandering and oh like where's the
authority in this voice I it's he's such
like a I don't know I don't want to do
an um is just they go back to the
question of decorum right and do we need
decorum this is some criticism that gets
leved at Trump all the time that he
doesn't have dorum that he doesn't act
presidential but maybe people don't want
that I mean I think of the British
Parliament and they I don't know that
anyone challenges anyone to a fight on
the floor of parliament but they yell
they're much similar in Australia too
exactly yeah I think you need about as
much decorum as Bernie Sanders like no I
didn't say that like that kind of
decorum like willing to kind of like
take off his tie or get his tie undone
if he's getting hot but like not throw
cups at people and stuff like that like
he he has a limit to the there was some
Senator I can't remember who it was who
threw a snowball at someone during a
debate on global I'll find the name was
that recently it was a long time ago cuz
I think I I was writing about it I think
it might have been tester from Alaska I
could be wrong on this I'll check in a
second but they were having a debate on
global warming and so he went out
scooped up Snow and then like threw it
across the chamber at him like there
have been weird funny moments and I
guess you know we weren't allowed to
throw snowballs at my school because
they could have pebbles in them and you
could hurt someone yeah same but I mean
there's a difference between decorum and
vital and you could say like okay we're
going downhill in terms of decorum
because we should all be polite and
things like that but in terms of just I
mean we have been accusing each other
Congressmen have have been accusing each
other of things like racism and
Corruption for a long time like that's
not new so I mean either way these
people are they're going they're
backstabbing each other they're trying
to ruin each other's careers is it a big
deal that they might I mean now it might
just be coming to the surface a little
bit more I don't think so I mean I think
the the lack of professionalism lack of
unity was already there it's just a
little bit more apparent now when Trum
snowball was uh Jim inhoff of Oklahoma
which is also where Mark Wayne Mullins
is from so maybe those Oklahoma
boys on the great PLS Trump when he said
Rosie O'Donnell is a fat didn't say that
well how did he say it she said Megan
Kelly asked about how you've insulted
women referring to some as you know fat
pigs or whatever and he says only Ros
odonnell okay and then that means in the
past he has called her a fat or he's
acknowledging that he did call her a fat
pig in the past I I don't think he's he
I don't think he was implying that he
literally said the words fat pig but
that he was implying that he's insulted
only Rosie odonnell or something like
that that I think is Al he meant
literally the only person he's called a
fat pig was her when it goes too far as
when you're in public office and you're
using your time publicly to insult
people like with mean like you dumb
idiot that thing because then that just
wastes time Wast taxpayer money I don't
want that in my office I agree but
personally I don't think calling someone
like a fat cow is any worse than
slandering someone as like a white
supremacist or a racist or whatever you
know you know what I mean like one might
be construed as like more Street and
fighting words but personally I would
rather be called a fat cow than you know
like an anti-semite that could actually
ruin your career in this day and age and
Congressmen have been calling people
that for a long time and I got to tell
you uh Ian more the more time they spend
insulting each other is less time they
spend on giving our money away for BS
government projects and War so I would
much prefer it you know IAL we talked
about this yesterday with war that I
would take the entire War budget and
just give it to some random guy because
some random American dude can spend it
infinitely better than we waste on all
these wars like 20 years in Afghanistan
but uh I would rather every single
member of Congress engaged in
narcissistic mudslinging on the on the
floor if it meant they weren't all in
lock step with funding war and foreign
inter kind of backs up my my suggestion
that we disperse the House of
Representatives if they're that useless
and you'd rather just see them insulting
each other they really to have no place
in this country we we we the people can
pass laws and bills into the Senate we
don't need these 450 stop Gap bribery uh
vulnerabilities anymore I disagree they
can join us in our citizen I think the
answer is not to abolish Congress it's
to reform or amend like all the people
need to get voted out we need better
rules clearly the system is busted Mike
had the fourth branch of government he
wanted to create called the national
initiative he was a senator from um um
from um Alaska and then it would have
created a fourth branch of government
that's the people the people would
represent local people to go and act as
another form of like a representative of
the people themselves instead of feel
like it just makes the government bigger
yeah and they more bribery no
vulnerabilties it's quite literally more
members of Congress either we do it
ourselves and there's 330 million of us
and you can't Bri us all no we need to
repeal the 17th Amendment and we need
people to focus on their local politics
more and stop acting like Kevin McCarthy
can do anything for you the dude does
not represent any of us in any way okay
he represents his district to the
federal government he does not represent
you as a person people think that our
federal elected representatives are
going to do anything for us at home and
that's what I I've long complained about
this you see these Congressional ads
where they're like I'm going to clean up
this town no you're not you're going to
Congress you're going to DC you're going
to go vote on war and other garbage if
you want to clean up your town if you
want to fix your crime you got to vote
for local reps and so a lot of and and
your Governors and your state senators
and things like that you want to know
why California's all messed up it's
because they they vote for these people
locally it's not anything the federal
government's doing yeah they can't also
they can't read these 3,000 page bills
it's but if we crowdsource it and we let
the entire US population have at it you
better believe there's going to be at
least 700 people that are going going to
go read those 3,000 Pages they do they
they do this yeah but then these are the
people that we need like pushing the
bills this was once
called the issue is that members of
Congress should have to the bills before
they vote on them but they don't do it
we should make it what was your idea you
make it a felony to vote on a bill that
you have not read yeah you have to swear
under oath that you've read the bill if
you're going to vote on it agre I I
would support that I don't know what the
argument against that would be they're
corrupt and they want to sell out their
positions to lobbyists right I mean but
the the the position that they could
defend publicly for having that be like
the spin I'm trying to think about like
I mean I think what they would say and I
don't believe this but the Counterpoint
would probably be you know it would be
impossible us to to produce effective
legislation that wasn't lengthy and so
actually you're making impossible for us
to get like you know they'd make like
the you're slowing us down argument but
maybe that's the point that's the point
yeah and that's why we want to get rid
of omnus Omnibus bills like what mat is
doing yeah like with spending bills you
used to actually have to have different
ones and that was a lot more efficient
because you could actually know where
the money was going but they want the
big bills so they can all slip their
pork in there and lobbyists can be like
haha like a little little nut for me
here little little presence and then uh
I don't know if you guys follow Rand
Paul's like every year he he exposes how
much money is spent on useless things
like giving Birds cocaine and studying
that or whatever it is but no it's it's
crazy and it's literally I would say
criminal how much how much they steal
from taxpayers on useless things he
calls that the Festivus his Festivus
recount or something like that Festivus
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at
timcast.net uncensored membersonly shows
exclusive thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time